Good evening.
Welcome to Day Two of the World Science Festival
and also offer my congratulations to the nine
new Kavli Prize laureates that were announced
just this morning from Oslo with the satellite
feed to New York at the World Science Festival.
And you know I'm not intimately familiar with
the work of those who won the prize in Nanoscience
or Neuroscience, but I am deeply familiar
with the work that won the prize in Astrophysics.
That work, as you may have read online already,
was the discovery, which was initially announced
in February, of the first direct detection
of gravitational waves.
An absolutely wondrous discovery.
Einstein predicted it a hundred years ago,
and now we have finally confirmed that.
And I'll have occasion to come back to that
discovery for a brief description, probably
a little bit later on, but suffice it to say
for now, that this discovery really feeds
into a pattern that we have been thrilled
to watch unfold over the course of a few hundred
years, where careful observation of the world,
careful mathematical analysis of the world
has shown us that science has this amazing
capacity to give us deep insight into the
nature of the world, the nature of reality,
which is, which is really just spectacular.
There's nobody who would deny that, except
maybe for the Republicans.
But.
No, no, no, no.
But my point, my point.
Ah stop that already.
You know.
No, my point is that this amazing progress
that's been made over the course of a few
hundred years has then emboldened scientists
to envision perhaps that all of the deep truths
of the world are susceptible to a scientific
explication.
Some have gone out to say that in fact, the
only true knowledge about the world can be
gleaned through scientific analysis.
Some have gone further still and describe
that everything that we hold dear, everything
that's important to us, everything that really
makes us human, is ultimately scientific at
its core.
In fact, there are some scientists who've
gone out, and I have to say typically it has
been physicists, who've gone out even in public
to make really scientific claims that this
sort of hegemony of science.
Everything is ultimately describable by science.
In fact, you know, perhaps you know one of
the most egregious examples of that occurred
just recently.
Let me just show you a little clip of this.
You and I are part of the expression of an
equation.
Yes, yes.
That I would even say that without this holographic
idea.
Math describes how your particles move, how
they behave how they interact.
You are a bag of particles governed by the
laws of physics.
That is, that is a great pickup line.
Brian Green.
Thank you so much.
Now I should say, being on The Colbert Report
is not exactly the place where you can have
the most nuance come out of your perspective
of how the world works.
I hope this will be a forum where my actual
views on this will become a little bit more
clear.
And I've got a couple of great friends who
are going to join us in this conversation
to explore those kinds of ideas and many that
are related to them.
So let me now bring them both on to the stage.
So first, Leon Wieseltier is the Isaiah Berlin
Senior Fellow in Culture and Policy at the
Brookings Institution.
He's the author among other books of the acclaimed
Kaddish.
He was a literary editor of The New Republic
from 1983 to 2014, and is now contributing
editor and critic at The Atlantic.
Please welcome Leon Wieseltier.
And we are also thrilled to be joined by Miguel
Nicolelis, who is the Duke School of Medicine
Distinguished Professor of Neuroscience, Professor
of Neurobiology, Biomedical Engineering and
Psychology and Neuroscience, founder of Duke
Center for Neuro-Engineering, founder and
scientific director of the Edmond and Lily
Safra International Institute for Neuroscience.
He’s also founder of the Walk Again Project,
an international consortium of scientists
and engineers dedicated to the development
of an exoskeleton device to assist severely
paralyzed patients in regaining full body
mobility.
So thank you for joining us.
Some of the questions that we may discuss
here tonight, just to rattle off a few: are
we nothing but the physical processes that
make us up as that ridiculous person said
in that clip.
Is consciousness nothing but the physical
chemical and biological processes in the brain,
or is there more to it?
Is empirical knowledge at the core of everything
that we should believe as being true?
Are there human experiences that are simply
unsuited for scientific explanation?
Does the brain experience give us a misleading
view of reality?
What defines us and what defines a human difference?
So these kinds of questions, which really
span art, culture, religion, creativity, are
all fair game for us tonight.
And let me just throw it to Leon to get us
going.
Thank you, my friend.
I am a militant unreconstructed humanist who
has many fewer hours in my day than you clearly
do.
I am, I confess, I am a little bit ashamed
at the level of my scientific knowledge but,
nonetheless some of the questions that I want
to talk about, that we will talk about tonight
are, are not just scientific questions.
They exceed the realms of science, or rather
the boundaries of the realm of science is
what we're going to be talking about.
And what I thought I would do just to start
it off, just for a few minutes, is to just
state a few beliefs that I have and et cetera.
So the first thing I want to say, the first
one, is just as a general matter that the
question of the place of science in life is
not a scientific question.
It's a philosophical question.
And no amount of scientific knowledge, no
amount of math, no amount of data, can tell
us where to put in our lives the experiments
and the math and the data.
That is something that is not a scientific
matter.
And one can, one gets into this interesting
discussion about what the word philosophy
would mean.
But et cetera.
The second belief I have is that we live in
many realms.
The human existence is comprised of many realms,
and that the differences between these realms
are real.
That is to say the difference, and we can
define what these realms are in various ways,
but that they have their categories that are
appropriate to each, their methods of inquiry
that are appropriate to each.
Their, the pace at which they're experienced
differ as well.
And each of these realms may shed light on
each other so that it can be illuminating
to answer a political question with an observation
about culture, or an economic question with
an observation about politics.
But none of these realms, none of these, no
single, no one of these realms can, deserves
to dominate all the others.
And none of the realms can be reduced to any
one of them.
And the attempt to reduce all the realms to
one is a kind of intellectual imperialism
and a colossal act of intellectual simplification.
Now most scientists that I've met are not
remotely guilty of this imperialism.
Practicing scientists, I must say that they
are one of the lessons that science, science
obviously doesn't just teach arrogance, it
also teaches humility.
And I've noticed that about my scientist friends
and so on.
But there are cases, there are cases, in which
both the natural certain and certain of the
natural sciences and certain of the social
sciences have presumed, have presumed to the
driver's seat in our explanation of human
life.
In the social sciences the most egregious
imperialist in my view is economics.
We now live in a society in which some of
our most reputed authorities on the subject
of happiness are economists, which does not,
happiness I must say.
I know this is archaic-happiness does not
seem to me to be an economic subject.
But again, I know that's very old fashioned.
We're living similarly in the in the era in
which we're living in which our culture certainly,
but also our intellectual life is increasingly
overwhelmed by data.
So that everything is being quantified.
One of the imperialisms that we have to be
vigilant about is the quantification of things
that cannot be quantified.
One of the questions that we have to ask as
a culture, is what can a number capture and
what can't the number capture.
And a lot of the direction and the quality
of our culture as it develops, will I think
, will be owed to whether or not we learn
to resist the lure of the easy clarity and
the easy confidence that numbers can give
people about things that cannot be mathematically
measured.
I remember once, and I used to work for a
magazine called The New Republic, and once
I was walking by where some young people who
work there and I overheard one young person
say to the other, I'll never forget this,
he said, "Well my friend ran into her yesterday
and she told him that she loves me, which
is a really important data point."
So I approached, you know I didn't want to
be obnoxious and I said you know, I promised
not to pry and forgive me if you think I am,
I just need to point out to you that the fact
that she loves you is not a data point.
And if you'd like to discuss this, then he
came in and we discussed it and etcetera,
etcetera.
I think you actually said, "It's not a fucking
data point," if I remember the story correctly.
You know I've got to say, Trump is everywhere.
Just.
But also, there are other examples one could
give.
So for example, consider the physical or the
chemical analysis of a painting.
Right?
It is possible.
You take a painting by Chardin, a painting
of cherries.
It is possible for a chemist to cast all kinds
of light on how those chromatic effects are
accomplished with an analysis of pigments,
chemical analysis of pigments, and so on.
But if the question that is being asked is,
"Why is that painting beautiful?", then the
chemical analysis of a painting is not going
to be able to answer that question.
Even though as I say, there will be nothing
false about the chemical analysis of the painting
because at some level, all those pigments
on Chardin's canvas are chemicals, et cetera
et cetera.
But could you imagine, sorry to jump in here,
but could you imagine at some point in the
far future, and Miguel you should weigh in,
we will understand the brain with such exquisite
precision and accuracy that the correlation
between the feeling of beauty, the choice
of colors that are being made by an aesthetic
judgment, we understand the physical processes
so well that correlate with all of those things
that yes, we'll never say that they are the
act of choice, they are the reason why Rembrandt
chose blue or red but we can say, it is just
a physical process that we understand completely
well and if we could look into the painter's
head, we would actually know that they are
choosing red at that moment and that's the
physical correlate of that choice.
I think well- go ahead.
As a neuroscientist, if I can get in.
Well I mean
First of all, I like to thank for the invitation.
This is a wonderful, is a wonderful opportunity
to debate these things and I think we're very
similar in our approaches, because even though
I grew up as a scientist recording brainstorms,
recording electrical brainstorms and trying
to look into thousands of neurons and find
exactly what you're talking about, the answer,
the prediction of a behavior that is about
to happen.
So far you can do for some things.
You can do, for instance, for motor acts you
can reasonably, we can link these days brains
to machines and can use just electrical activity
from human or animal brains to control directly
the movements of a robotic device.
Yet, when we go to exact the questions that
you were raising, I start wondering myself
as a neuroscientist, not that I'm disputing
your point that you know the laws of physics,
the brain has to obey the laws of physics,
but to some degree, certain attributes that
came with the degree of complexity that evolution
endowed us may not be simply predicted by
the same, you know, mechanisms that are used
to apply to understand the universe that is
up there.
Because the universe that is between our ears,
I dare to say in front of a famous theoretical
physicist, is much more complex.
It's much more complex in many domains.
A small footnote, I would say that I completely
agree with you and the reason why I do physics,
is because it is so much simpler.
And I mean that quite seriously.
We have been able in quantum mechanics to
understand the behaviors of systems with a
few particles we can do that really well and
that's exciting.
But you give me something with all of the
connections and particles inside the head,
there's no physicist alive who can do anything
with that.
And I would just provoke you by saying that
all this beautiful, and I'm a big fan of quantum
mechanics and physics in general, although
I am of course just an amateur.
But the beauty of it is all that you guys
have done came from this, came from the biology
that evolution produced.
So I'd like to say, I mean like that then
what is out here, is the human universe.
Because this is epic told by the human brain
is a reconstruction the best we can.
Science is that, in my opinion like Niels
Bohr used to say, it's the best attempt we
have that you know to describe what is out
there.
It's the best shot that we have of reconstructing
this and is actually coming all these concepts;
electrons, quarks, fields is all coming from
the biology of our brains.
Wait, so are you saying that when we contact
aliens in the far, far future and we asked
them for their view of how the universe is
put together, there's a chance that they're
going to come out with something radically
different from anything that we're discovered
here cause their biology is different?
We were talking about this backstage.
I think if, I'm from the 60s so I'm Mr. Spock's
fan right.
Growing up in Brazil, Mr. Spock was a hero.
You're talking about the Star Trek Mr. Spock
Star Trek, yeah, yeah.
-or the other guy? Dr. Spock.
I think they're both doctors, but anyway.
But I would say exactly, that's my point.
That if you go to Vulcan, in natural selection
evolution in Vulcan has been completely different
and a complete different brain has evolved
with complete different properties.
Mathematics, logic, science may be very different
the way they expressed these concepts and
the way they reconstruct a universe and there
is a chance, I cannot deny that, that they
may come up with an explanation that may have
some overlaps of ours, but may be completely
different from what we are.
And not isomorphic not just a different language.
You're saying , you're saying literally different.
But I have to believe that, that if there
are Jews on other planets say, (laughter)
that, that no matter how different their fates
will be, and I hope they're very different,
that the, even if they come from different
biological origins, that each in their own
way by their own path can hit upon whatever
is actually true about the universe and that
we do not need to condemn ourselves to the
idea that the different biology, do a kind
of biological cosmic relativism, whereby every
brain will have its own truth.
I thought you were going to say they have
a guilt complex that comes from your mother
or something.
No, no, no.
I said Jews on other planets.
On that planet of yours, besides Jews there
are Brazilian's.
Yes.
They'll come and say I doubt it.
Let's try to do the experiment.
It's a difficult experiment because you know,
they haven't arrived yet.
But I think we should be open to this as I
think after what I heard from you.
I think neuroscience has to be open to all
the issues that you raised, because when we
talk about the brain, we tend to, as neuroscientists,
we tend to you know be away or try to be away
from these big questions.
And I think that it's time to, for us to open
up.
Let me just say two things.
I think first, there is a difference between
neuroscience and the reception and the use
of neuroscience in our culture.
And one of the things that I see happening
that so alarms me is the way in which more
and more people are now sitting at the edge
of their chairs waiting for the latest bulletin
from neuroscience so they can understand how
to proceed or understand their own lives.
You know, so you get you get books that tell
you that Proust is a neuroscientist for example,
to which my thought is immediately, well if
Proust is a neuroscientist and I've already
read Proust, then I don't need neuroscience.
Or that Jane Austen is a game theorist.
We've had that too, similar response, similar
response.
So I think that one of the things we have
to be aware of, there is the science, and
then there's the uses to which the science
is put.
Generally, it's been my observation that people
do not like living with uncertainty.
And the two, the two sources, the two most
reliable sources of certainty that they can
find, are science and religion.
Now the search for certainty in both of them
often betrays the spirit of both science and
religion.
But people need, they need to feel that in
some way their lives are an inevitable outcome
of something.
So are those different?
I mean how-
Yeah I think they operate differently and
I think that that's vulgar science and vulgar
religion because obviously doubt and skepticism
is an important part of both.
But people don't always describe religion
in that way of course, right?
I mean that's a, probably a distinct view
from what most people envision as an environment
in which faith is meant to guide your perspective
as opposed to some sort of skeptical, quizzical
point of view.
I think there is no, no I think, I mean this
is just a detour cause I wanted to make another
point we're saying, but I think that there
is no religious tradition that doesn't include,
not just in its depths but in any one of its
sophisticated levels, important elements of
doubt, skepticism.
In other words, it is I say it's a vulgar
idea of religion.
The belief in God raises as many questions
as it answers except for people who don't
want questions raised.
And people have a powerful interest, some
people, in not having questions raised.
They want the matter settled and they look
for, as I say, for sources of certainty, for
sources of intellectual confidence about their
circumstances.
And they don't like the feeling that they
are burdened with the full responsibility
of their circumstances etcetera, etcetera.
But the other thing I wanted to say when we
talked about the painter, about the painter,
it's very important to make a distinction,
I think, between causes and reasons.
I think that an artist's, an artist's production,
a painting has both.
It has causes in the sense that in some way
it was the product.
I mean, you know the Divine Comedy was the
product of Dante’s brain, not just his mind.
But reasons are something else.
In other words, reasons are, the question
of why an artist made certain decisions both
small decisions of execution and large decisions
of conception and interpretation.
I don't believe that those decisions can be
explained only in terms of causes.
I really don't.
No, no, I'm with you because one of the things
I have been looking lately, because of this
interest in larger scale brain activity and
how it may either determine or influence art
and other aspects is that, there was a moment
in our history of art the people just painting
like a photographer, reproducing form and
shaping very precise.
And that was how an artist was rewarded.
By basically reproducing what is out here
in great detail.
And suddenly, in the beginning of the 19th
century, and that's the painting I brought
from Turner you know, shape start being exploded.
Things started exploding and the painters
just start saying, "I don't want to paint
what is out there and everybody sees equal.
I want to paint what I see, what comes from
me, from the inside.
I want to representation of my brain's own
point of view."
That's how I as a neuroscientist, I would
put.
In light, the reflection of light, like what
we see here in this steamboat of Turner, was
the basically the beginning of the Impressionist
movement in which shape suddenly starts to
disappear, and in modern art it exploded.
Funny enough, this explosion of space, this
disappearance of space, coincides with the
investigation in physics of the very little
and the very big.
When you go back to the atomists, atomistic
view, you know, of nature at the end of 19th
century, and you come with you know quantum
mechanics and general relativity any space
in our conception explodes from the very tiny
to the huge to the whole universe.
And I found it very beautiful that these analogies
or this his period shows this correlation
in art and science.
Where you are coming out of these boundaries.
But I would say that if you look at that Turner,
that whereas it's certainly true that he was
studying the difficulties and the dramas of
perception itself, I wouldn't read it entirely
as an allegory or an expression of his inner
states.
I think that he would have said that that
painting was what it looked like.
I don't think he would have said just that
it was what it looked like to me, even though
he would have been the first to acknowledge
the subjectivity, the partiality, of his perspective.
So I really believe, and the same with the
Impressionists, the same with all, they were
making they were making a claim about the
difficulty of capturing perception the extent
to which perception is involved in our understanding
of objectivity.
But I don't think any of them were saying
this is just an expression of my brain.
But what I was, I was trying to say is that
my conception of the brain right now after
30 years is going from different models of
what we actually see as a result is this collision
of what is out here in his being brain in
what is the brain's own point of view?
What is the brain is expecting as reality?
And it's this collision.
And I remember Picasso saying when a journalist
asked him in Paris what was that painting
about.
One of his Cubist paintings and he said, "Well
if I knew, I would not have painted it," you
know?
Yeah.
Well you know there's this, you remind me
that this wonderful story about Matisse who
near the end of his life was commissioned
to paint a fresco in a small church in Vence
in the south of France.
And a filmmaker asked for permission to film
him painting, and he granted permission and
then when it was over the filmmaker showed
him the film, and Matisse was horrified and
didn't want the film shown.
And when the filmmaker asked why the artist
said, "Because your film makes it look like
I knew what I was doing."
I think you know there is, again I think that
this whole thing we're getting at in different
ways about the, the extent to which we can
invoke subjectivity and objectivity and what
the relation you know Amartya Sen has this
wonderful concept that he calls positional
objectivity, meaning that and what I think
it means is that obviously there is no such
thing as a view from nowhere.
Right there is no such thing as perfect objectivity.
But the impossibility of that perspective,
whatever it would be like it would, it's even
impossible for us to imagine, to conceive
of what it would be like.
That does not condemn us to imprisonment within
subjectivities either scientifically or humanistically
conceived.
That there is, there is some negotiation between
what comes from inside and what is outside
that allows us to make certain claims about
our representations of things outside to say
that they are accurate or true or deep etc.,
etc.
So what is that?
Can I ask you to drill down a little bit,
because I love the idea that you describe
of the distinction between reason and causes.
And it, and it feels right.
I mean all of us feel like we make these choices
and it's more than just the causal influence
of things that are happening inside us.
There's something else.
But is that real or is that an illusion?
Is that just the right kind of language in
order to capture a human experience?
I mean, I'm interested in both of your perspectives
on this, but is there anything more beyond
the physical, when we're talking about what's
happening up here?
Or is it just the physical and ultimately
does it all come down to chemistry and biology
and physics, or is it more than that?
Now there are people who spend their lives
struggling with the so-called hard question
of consciousness, right?
I mean, the easy question that most people
describe is: look we can understand how the
brain processes information in the world,
takes it in, and is able to generate behaviors
from those stimuli.
But the hard part is usually to assess what
it means to feel, what it means to actually
sense what's happening out there in the world.
And I, at one point, and still am to some
degree was a complete reductionist.
Right?
It is just the molecules and atoms and the
one thing that slightly made me question that,
and I still do at some level, is, you know,
these things, was Colbert well Colbert did
it too.
He always does.
But, but there's this old neuroscientist story
about Mary in the room.
You know the one that I'm talking about?
Now we have like, I don't know if everyone's
familiar with this.
I don't know if it will be that useful, but
for me it was a real kicker in the head when
I first encountered this and we have a little,
little video clip to describe this scenario.
So if you can bring up that that Mary's room
video that would be great.
Imagine that in the far, far future, there's
a brilliant neuroscientist named Mary, who
for some reason is confined to a room in which
everything appears in black and white.
There is no color of any sort whatsoever.
Mary can study and access and examine the
world outside but it all comes to her only
in black and white.
Even so, Mary is able to reach a goal that
has long eluded humankind.
She totally and fully unravels every last
detail about the structure of function, physiology,
chemistry, biology, and physics of the brain.
She knows absolutely everything there is to
know about the behavior of the brain's every
neuron, every molecule, every atom.
She knows precisely what goes on inside our
heads, the details of all neural processes
that cascade when we see a beautiful red rose,
when we marvel at a rich blue sky, or when
we encounter something in a curious shade
of art.
One day, Mary is allowed to leave her room
and the very first thing she sees is a plump
red tomato.
Here's the question: from this experience
of the color red, will Mary learn anything
new?
Will she shrug and just move on?
Or will she be surprised, or thrilled, or
moved, or gain some new insight through this
actual experience of color?
And if she does what does that tell us about
the limits of a purely physical description
of the brain and consciousness?
Of course, I mean the point of that story,
which was raised I guess in nineteen eighty
five I think it was, Frank Jackson neuroscientist.
I mean the idea of philosophy, the idea was,
if she does learn something new by virtue
of actually experiencing color, or it could
be anything.
It could be love.
It could be passion.
It could be anything.
If the act of experiencing something tells
you more than just what you learned by understanding
the, the physiology of it, then there's got
to be something more in the world than just
the processes.
I mean, is that, did that ever kick your head
the way it did mine when I first encountered
it?
Well I can describe to you in a recent experiment
that goes into this line.
We did in our lab we got rats, adult rats
and we put infrared sensors implant in their
heads.
And as you know, mammals can not detect, they
cannot see infrared light because they don't
have photoreceptors for their wavelength.
And they don't have temperature sensors that
get, you know, a temperature sensing for infrared.
And so we implanted those and we basically
put animals in the infrared universe where
they have to track infrared beams to find
sugar water.
And they love to go after sugar water.
But what we did was to get the output of these
infrared detector electrical output that describes
the magnitude and the orientation of the beam,
directly into the touch cortex the part of
the brain that codes for touching.
And in about three days, adult rats that have
never experienced infrared were touching otherwise
invisible light.
They were actually tracking beams of infrared
in finding sugar water just by experiencing,
what we don't know because we still cannot
interrogate them, but they were having some
sort of tactile experience and they were able
to track that infrared light.
So next time, we put them in the visual cortex.
Because after all, visual cortex is used to
detect electromagnetic radiation.
And in six hours, these rats were able to
track infrared light with one detail.
They could merge infrared wavelength with
visible spectrum.
So we had a task in which half of the message
was coming visible light and half in infrared.
And to solve the maze and find the sugar water,
they had to combine both of them, and they
did.
So and these are adult rats, adult brains
that according to many years, although the
brain is plastic throughout life that piece
of cortex would be dedicated just to visible
spectrum or touch.
And that's what I was trying to say.
I was just trying to say that the old vision
that they brain is just a passive decoder
of what is there, I think is gone.
But that's still describing a functional response
to a stimulus that a third party has access
to, isn't it?
No, because the cells in the brain when we
look at individual neurons, they now had responses
to both tactile and infrared in a very nonlinear
way.
We couldn't predict how these neurons would
map that relationship.
So they create an internal representation
in which it was not predicted by the models
that, the linear models that we're using to
try to predict, that and the animal could
make sense of that.
But it's all still physics and physiology.
There's nothing more than that, right?
No.
Absolutely.
But that's the reason I'm saying .
But is that your view?
No, no, I'm just trying to say that the reason
the brain is so complex.
And although the laws of physics of course
have the basis of its functionally is there
is a self adapting complex system.
It's like an orchestra that when it plays
a song, at the very moment the note is produced
it's already changing the instruments to produce
the next note.
And this is a recursive loop that goes continuously.
But there are many ways to play a song.
There are many ways to solve.
There's no single correct way to play.
No, no effect that's not the principle.
You know and it's I mean I think I mean just
speaking for my own neurons, I think that
only, only a physicalist could have come up
with that question.
The idea of whether or not Mary actually learned
something new the first time she saw red.
Yeah.
So what's your view?
Well, she learned about the richness of the
visual world.
She learned about, she may have felt gratitude
about being alive right.
She may have been stimulated by the heat of
the color.
I mean there are there are lots of things
she learned.
But does that mean that there's more to the
world beyond?
Yes look, look you know we get into these
definitions of reality and if you, if physicalists
want to describe all these nonphysical humanistic
things that the rest of us live for as illusions
then what I would say is fine, but illusions
are real too.
Everything is real.
Even unreality is real.
But couldn't it actually be...
Wait, wait, wait, what I wanted to say was
no, no, no.
I think that, how should I put it?
Biology can in some, biology can be responsible
in some way from my loving a woman but biology
cannot be responsible for my loving my wife.
Because the experience of love is an experience
that has reasons and that, that is involved.
It involves us as self-interpreting beings
with desires.
And so all the biology in the world cannot
account for my bond with a particular woman.
All the biology in the world.
And, and the only question that really interests
me, if the question that we ask is, what is
the meaning of human life?, which is a perfectly
good question, my, or what is the human difference?
Let's say.
I believe that even if ninety nine point nine
percent of our, of our lives as animals, as
creatures can be explained in scientific or
physicalist terms.
That point 1 percent is what we mean by the
human difference.
Right.
And I want to believe that.
And I want you to convince me of that.
Well, go right ahead.
I'm human and I'm trying and trying.
But can I just I push a little bit a little,
bit harder just so I can get it.
I've tried.
Actually, you know what, you live that way.
I do.
And I live with a certain kind of tension
between my understanding of how the world
is put together according to scientific insight
and my intuition, the intuition that everybody
has that somehow isn't really describing it
all.
It's the, the point 1 percent or more than
that ,that somehow is something else.
But, but here's the way that I've tried to
make sense of it.
And the reason I'm bringing this up is because
it seems to resonate with the description
you gave a little while ago of the distinct
realms that can somehow inform each other
even though they can't be reduced to one another.
Because one of the deepest lessons in physics,
is that we can understand the universe scale
by scale by scale.
What I mean by that is, look you know if Isaac
Newton had to understand molecules and atoms
and quark's and neutrinos in order to be able
to write down his laws of motion he would
never have made any progress.
Thankfully he was able to look out into the
world and see ordinary macroscopic objects,
rocks and the moon, and he was able to limit
his attention to that ordinary scale, write
down equations that were able to describe
those processes, and it worked in that environment,
in that domain.
And then as we got better at examining the
world, we were able to penetrate more deeply.
We did get to the molecules and atoms and
holy cow, a whole new set of equations, a
whole new vocabulary needed to be brought
forward.
The vocabulary of quantum physics and it works
incredibly well at that scale.
They're not in contradiction.
You can get one from the other.
So that's a preamble to the way that I would
try to make sense of what you said which is,
look yeah.
So when we're talking about the human difference,
when we're talking about trying to explain,
say why one loves their wife, maybe it is
ultimately all the physical but the language,
the relevant language to use is not that of
quantum physics.
There's just a better language.
But nevertheless, it still is just all quantum
physics down there acting itself out even
though that language offers no insight.
There's another point I think is important
to be made because I think we're in the same
the same camp here, is that just because you
have a scientific view or try to look for
a scientific explanation for this phenomenon,
you know love creativity you know faith belief.
It doesn't mean that you are devaluing the
uniqueness of the human condition.
As a scientist, as a neuroscientist, I think
one of the biggest missions of science, in
my humble opinion, this moment is, to bring
the uniqueness of the human condition to the
forefront.
Because we are not machines.
We are not just a super complex digital computers.
Everybody talks about computers.
Everybody talks about technology.
And I use technology.
I love technology and I connect brains to
machines for a living but I think, if I can
say.
that no rational would ever come up with the
Internet.
Yes.
But what I'm trying to say is that I have
seen the last two decades or so with the speed
of integration technology in our daily routines,
sort of almost, not I wouldn't say a devaluing,
but putting the second plane, the uniqueness
of our human attributes.
And what I'm concerned about, is that our
over, over experience, over immersion with
machines may actually be contributing to trimming
some of this beauty.
Some of this unique human condition.
But I've read your book and
Thank you.
I read yours too.
In hardcover or soft cover?
But you know, the argument that you gave in
your book strikes me as less radical than
the description that might be gleaned from
what you just said.
So tell me if I'm wrong.
What I got out of your argument in the book
was that , if you focus on modeling the brain
as a digital computer, so in more technical
terms like a Turing machine, maybe we don't
need to go down that trajectory, but if more
or less you model as a digital computer then
you gave some convincing arguments that that
ultimately will fail.
That that's not what's going on.
No chance of working.
But it seemed quite clear that if you were
to go beyond the domain of digital computers
into more sophisticated kinds of computational
devices, maybe probabilistic Turing machines
or things of that sort, then the arguments
that you gave would not be as airtight.
So are you really saying that there's more
to us than machines, or are you saying that
there's more to us than digital computers?
No.
The argument of the book was about digital
computers, Turing machines.
In fact, we finished by saying that devices
like quantum computers for instance, is an
open question.
We, you know, we didn't approach, Ronald Cicurel
and I didn't approach that issue.
What we're trying to say using, as you saw,
Godel's incomplete theorem and other arguments.
Even Turing's own original work is that humans,
or human brain, is a hyper computer, is something
above a Turing machine.
And a Turing machine would never be able to
simulate
But for this conversation, isn't that just
another kind of machine?
It's a more sophisticated machine, but it's
just a machine.
It's a very interesting question.
Now I didn't mean to.
No
No, no, I didn't mean to either.
It's just the crowd gets me worked up a little
bit but.
I think, I think, I think our rationale is
that organic, organic systems like a brain,
particularly the human brain, primate brain,
human brain, they, they obeyed the laws of
physics, but they are getting to a realm of
complexity, a level of complexity where you
have so many variables interacting and resonating
with one another in that you basically create
a level of complexity where a new type of
information may be produced.
We're debating that in fact not just digital
information.
So the example I gave we're debating was,
a classic example in medicine in neuroscience,
is the phantom limb sensation where you have
a patient, I had a few, where you have an
amputation.
The patient is fully aware that his leg, let's
say, was amputated but he's having a feeling.
He's having pain on a piece of the body that
doesn't exist anymore.
No digital machine would be able to solve
that ambiguity, because you can come forgive
me you can come in front of the patient with
the leg amputated and he would say, "No, no,
no.
I know that you amputated my leg.
But I feel perfectly fine that I'm touching
the corner of the bed with my toe and my toe
is hurting."
Because that's what he had a problem that
that required amputation.
So you have that ambiguity where at the same
time on the one side there is no leg.
But the brain is telling him you have your
leg.
But I would, I would reject the analogy of
the nonphysical as non-material dimensions
of human experience to the fantasy, the fantasy
of a phantom limb.
I'm just using it as an example.
But that seems to me precisely the problem.
I mean from where I sit, the burden of proof
for me falls not on people who wish to prove
that we're not a machine, but on people who
wish to prove that we are.
To me it's perfectly obvious.
As a matter of lived experience that a purely
mechanistic account will not be able to properly
describe or explain some of the central experiences
of human life.
Right.
I want you to really convince me of that so
I go home tonight, I'm no longer troubled
by the tension between my understanding that
you and I, sort of in that clip, are ultimately
composed of ingredients that are governed
by laws, or complex ingredients and complex
interactions.
But what goes beyond that?
But the questions you have to ask yourself,
my friend, is why you want to believe the
other way.
I don't
You see.
In other words, what is the seduction of the
mechanistic or physicalist account.
Actually is not seductive, it's repulsive
I find it repulsive too, I find that -
So we're together.
We are.
You know, we are.
Completely repulsive.
I mean I think one should.
Not you.
But I think you know, you can make a distinction.
There is science and there is scientism.
Yes.
There is biology and there is biology-ism.
There is economics and there is economy-ism.
The -ism is the thing that makes me nervous.
The -ism is that imperialistic extension,
the idea that-there's nothing controversial
about saying that for the past five hundred
years for as long as it's existed, Michelangelo's
David has been marble, has been stone.
Perfectly uncontroversial and that, at every
moment if we look at it, it's still stone.
The physical account of it is always true.
It also is incredibly banal and doesn't tell
me terribly much about why it is that I'm
staring at that statue.
So scientism is the idea that all you need
to know is that it's stone.
And the humanistic critique of that would
be, nobody in their right mind would deny
that it is stone
Yeah.
In other words, the idea that, that, that
the scientific, the physicalist, the material,
the biological, the chemical, you name it,
that all those dimensions are, are, are at
play.
I mean that's not under any threat from any
sane humanist, right?
But there is the opposite.
There is the opposite.
But isn't that a little bit of a straw man?
Because I think most of us would totally agree
that if you just describe it as marble, that
that couldn't possibly be enough to answer
the questions for why we're staring at it.
But if you have a fantastically rich and nuanced
appreciation of the brain this gloppy, grey
thing that's interpreting the photons that
are bouncing off of the statue, then you might,
you might be able to give a completely straightforward,
scientific account of why it is that you're
staring at it.
Well that scientific-it would then you give
the account of how such an explanation would
explain the beauty of the statue.
Yeah, so, so-
Not the contours of it.
Yeah.
You know, I mean
So I wish that I could go.
No, no, but you don't wish that you could.
I wish that, I wish that I could, you're absolutely
right, but, but could I just lay out the framework?
And then you can critique it, you know.
The framework, I think would be, you have
this biological system that's gone through
thousands and thousands of years of evolution
in order to be able to have propagated and
survived.
And therefore it has a certain biological,
chemical, physiological, physical structure
such that when it encounters certain kind
of macroscopic forms, it responds in a particular
way and I could imagine, we can't do it, but
I could imagine, that we one day will able
be able to give an account where we will say,
"Aha, this brain is going to respond in such,
a such a way when it encounters this kind
of stimulus."
Right.
Let me just say that those responses will
eventually be articulated in words and in
concepts.
Yes.
Now there is an infinite variety -
-of words and concepts that could be used
to form what we do whenever we see such things
which is an interpretation.
Yes.
We interpret everything.
But that's a very good point, because even
from a biological evolutionary point of view,
from my point of view as a neuroscientist,
each one of the human beings that ever lived,
live, and will live, are unique because it
did absolute explosion of combinations of
states that you could produce in the brain.
We'll get, you know, millions of people looking
at a Michelangelo and have a complete different
interpretation and the feeling, a reading
of what is there, because even though what
you said is absolutely correct, evolution,
in fact I like to say that the process of
evolution is almost like a copyright protection
mechanism for copying our brains, because
it was done through a infinite sequence of
random events that cannot be reproduced, you
know, even if you could rewind the tape of
life.
Stefan Jay Gould said that if you rewind the
tape and let it go again, we wouldn't be here.
Right.
So I think that biology would account for
exactly what you say.
That the combinatorial explosion of connectivity
in the states that the mind can come up because
the brain has a history.
Each one of them-ours.
Each one of our brains has a history.
He has a, he has built its own point of view
over our lifetime and is unique.
But if I replicate that brain without having
it gone through all of that history, right?
Lets be just fanciful for half a moment.
If I somehow was able to replicate it atom
by atom, neuron by neuron, even though it
didn't have that historical evolution leading
to the form that it currently has, presumably
you would agree that it would react in the
same way as the brain that went through all
that process.
I'm not a mathematician, but wouldn't there
be an almost like an intractable problem?
Because it would take the age of the universe
to simulate that thing or more.
Billions of years of simulation because you're
talking about trillions of parameters that
have to be updated in a millisecond to be
able to see it.
Otherwise your model will divert.
I wasn't even saying simulate.
I'm saying build another biological object.
Oh that's easy Brazil we know how to do that.
It's very simple.
You know so the real question is: is that
it?
Maybe you could make a President.
Yeah we can make it here.
Here.
There, oh there?
There I don't know.
So, so, so to what extent is the history vital
to the function?
Well I think the evolutionary history is pivotal,
of course.
We are, we are, we are, our brains are reflecting
the evolutionary history of our species is
millions of years.
But we also have the ontogeny of this brain.
And the life, the unique life, of individual
with the brain.
In my opinion, is building its own internal
point of view as we grow up, and as reason
humans have so long of a time of postnatal
development, and why we play so much.
We are playing scenarios, we are practicing
scenarios, and we are building an account
of what is out here.
And in my conception of the brain, every time
I'm about to look to something, I'm actually
seeing before I look, because my brain has
a hypothesis.
He has, he has an expectation of what I'm
about to see.
And it's this conclusion, or this collision,
I'm sorry, of what is here with this expectation
Yeah, it's a kind of scientists Kantianism,
or some kind.
Meaning that we dont- there is no such thing
as naked sense experience.
We -actually bring organizing concepts for,
in other words, we don't look there and see
seven brown lines is raw sense data and then
look at combining them into a chair.
We see a chair.
And then we begin to break it down into what
the sensory data are that allowed us to see
that.
But I think this is actually why when you
say beauty, when I say beauty or happiness,
when I see something as beautiful.
It's very difficult to define, because my
internal definition of beautiful carries my
entire lifetime story, my evolutionary story
in the, in the salt and pepper of my previous
experiences, which are very different from
yours.
Which are very different from his.
Can raise here a related question, which is
the degree to which, you know, the title of
the program is "To Unweave a Rainbow," right?
It comes from a Keats poem, this notion that
science somehow pulls things apart and destroys
the beauty and the wonder of it all.
And you know Richard Feynman had a perspective,
a great physicist, had a perspective on this,
just want to get your sense of it, can you
show the Richard Feynman flower clip?
I have a friend who is an artist and he has
sometimes taken a view, which I don't agree
with very well.
You hold up a flower and say, "Look how beautiful
it is."
And he says, "You see his eyes and can see
how beautiful this is.
But you as a scientist, take this all apart
and it becomes a dull thing."
And I think that he's kind of nutty.
First of all, although I may not be quite
as refined and aesthetic as he is, but I can
appreciate the beauty of a flower.
At the same time, I see much more about the
flower than he sees.
I mean, it's not just beauty at this dimension,
there's also beauty at a smaller dimension.
I could imagine cells in there.
Also the processes, the complicated actions,
which also have a beauty.
The fact that the colors in the flower evolve
in order to attract insects upon him, is interesting.
It means the insects can see the color.
It heads a question.
Why is it aesthetic?
All kinds of interesting questions which science
only adds to the excitement, the mystery,
and the awe of a flower.
It only adds.
I don't understand how it subtracts.
Thoughts?
Well I look, obviously-well in the first place,
there's no question that science itself and
its discoveries have been one of the greatest
revealers of beauty that man has ever experienced
or devised.
And that's why there are many scientific results
having to do both with science in the small
and the cell and then you in the galaxy, before
which one feels not just the feeling of being
present,, being present before beauty but
even before the sublime.
Yes.
Which is another form of aesthetic experience.
What I would say about, what about Feynman,
is that the whole thing begs the question,
which is to say that the point is not that
scientists-
The good news is that science is powerless
to destroy beauty even if it thinks it can.
That's the good news.
So all these physicalists running around thinking
they're, they're murdering to dissect they're
wrong.
They're dissecting, but they're not murdering,
except for themselves, except for themselves.
And a pity on them.
But, but Feynman begs the question in the
sense that when he says you can experience
the beauty not just at the flower but also
at the cellular level, I would say all right,
but there still remains the question of what
that experience of beauty is at any level,
at any level.
So, and the idea that the experience of beauty
can be explained scientifically at any level
of scientific revelation, seems imperialistic
to me and seems incorrect to me.
So the awe that, I mean, his instruction is:
don't think that it's just at the level of
the flower.
We scientists can see it too.
And I say yeah, but then I say to him, "Well
what exactly do you think you're experiencing?"
And if science could give a real, it can't
yet, but if it really could get an answer.
It never will.
Well just go with me for half a moment.
If it could give an answer to that would it,
what impact would that have on your perspective?
Let's say, let's just say, would it matter
to you?
Would you say, "Oh goodness gracious, I can
no longer think about the world as I once
did," or would your view just sort of sit
on top-
In terms of my own experience, it wouldn't
matter one whit.
What would matter to me is that I don't want
my fellow citizens to believe that they are
nothing but manipulatable physical beings
who, who lack- I don't want, I don't want
their horizon for- the possible horizon of
their experience.
I don't want their sense of what, of what
their spiritual attainments can be to be shrunk
by the idea that it's all just matter.
but does it have to be shrunk?
Well, generally it's had that effect.
But it doesn't need to
No, it doesn't need to at all.
Not at all.
I think, I think the two views can find a
common ground because
Not at all.
I think the definitions of beauty that we
saw with Feynman's description is in the eye
of the beholder, right?
You can-what I think-my criticism of the reductionist
view, as a scientist, is that yes there is
beauty and there's always an adventure in
the intellectual journey of breaking things
apart and trying to fix them, because physics
was so successful.
Physics was so successful.
Everybody thought, OK the recipe for success
in other disciplines is just to get that model
and try to apply it to, to biology and other
things.
And the problem is, is pretty much what you're
saying.
We are breaking apart.
We try to find the fundamental elements in
biology is very difficult, because when you
say "life," it is not like when you say "matter."
Yes.
When you say "matter," you say is made of
molecules, is made of atoms, is made of the
nucleus, and quarks, and strings.
When you say "life," for biologists it's not
very easy to, to come with this infinite reductionist
view of what it is.
So our problem is that the science of complexity
in biology is at its infancy.
We really can't- we have very few ideas and
tools to put things together once we break
them apart.
But then do you think that the question of
what complexity means and how it should be
interpreted would be changed or in any way
affected by the discovery of unimaginable
degrees of complexity?
In other words, does it really matter that
the complexity is going to get greater in-for
the search for what the meanings of that complexity
will be?
Yeah I never thought about it, but what I
can tell you is that the way we approach a
complex system today like the brain, is with
tools that we approach systems that are not
self adaptive, self-referral, in as complex
as this system is.
Because when you're talk about a functioning
brain, you are talking about an exchange of
information from multiple levels, from the
circuit level, from the cellular level, from
the molecule, from the quantum level.
And you're also talking about a descriptive
system, like Prigogine used to say, with environment.
You're exchanging information, exchanging
energy, materials.
Right?
You have an island of negative entropy trying
to, to keep together, not to dissipate.
And the tools that we have to approach these
systems are, in my opinion, at their infancy,
and that's the problem.
You can break it apart.
And in physics it works very nicely, but in
biology we should be able to put it together.
And that's where the difficulty emerges.
But I think we're sort of both, from different
ways, arriving in a similar place.
It reminds me of, do you know the parable?
There was a British philosopher named John
Wisdom who once gave a parable, created a,
made up a parable about the question of whether
or not-of what's called the Cosmological Proof
of God's Existence, the argument for design,
that owing to the complexity that we see in
nature, there must be a designer.
So Wisdom made up the following parable: There
were two explorers in a jungle, let's say
the Amazon jungle, and they're cutting away
and cutting away and cutting away and they
enter deeper and deeper into the jungle and
suddenly, they come upon an acre of perfectly
manicured and landscaped lawn, a beautifully
kept garden.
So one of them says, "It's chance."
The other says, "No, no, no, there's a gardener."
So the one who says it's chance says, "You
know, why don't we stay the night and see
if a gardener turns up."
So they stay the night.
Of course, no gardener turns up.
So the man says, "I told you there's no gardener."
So the one who believes there's a gardener
say "No, no, no, all that means is that maybe
we couldn't see him at night.
Okay we'll rig up some lights."
They stay.
Nobody comes.
"You see I told you, it was chance."
He says, "No, no, no, it's just a gardener
that can't be seen at night in a light.
Then let's put up an electric force field."
They put up an electric force field.
Nobody comes.
"You see I told you, it's chance."
He says, "No, no, all we know is that the
gardener is invisible at night in the light
and immune to the electric force field."
They do this on and on until the first one
says to the second, "You know what, let's
go because what you mean by a gardener, I
mean by chance."
You just described a Swiss garden.
Yes, exactly.
Because I have been there for three years.
They look pristine and I've never seen the
gardener ever.
So I got a question from you from our streaming
audience: Do you think there's moral worth
to taking one position that you're describing
over another?
Why might it be valuable to accept the limits
of science?
Well look, we haven't talked about the moral
implications of these things, and the reason
I didn't bring them up is because the first
thing that matters is whether or not what
we're saying is true, not whether we're saying
it's morally useful or socially-that it has
any kind of social utility.
I think obviously there are different scientific
accounts of human life that have different
ethical implications.
You know, you just look at the history of
the moral interpretation of Darwinism, for
example.
In the late 19th century, Darwinism was interpreted
in an almost fascist way, the survival of
the fittest and so on.
But then liberal evolutionary biologist, 20
and 30 years ago, began to argue that actually
natural selection is of course the case.
But what we're naturally selected for is not
cruelty but altruism.
And so you have a whole literature about the
evolutionary origins of altruism which accepts
the biological evolutionary determinism at
some level but has a totally different moral
implication.
The real question is not-the first question
has to be not what are the different moral
implications of different scientific pictures
of life.
The real question is: does morality need a
basis in science at all?
Right.
You know it is, are ethics based- are ethics
naturalistic or are they not?
And there are obviously different views about
this.
Well the traditional view, of course, is that
science doesn't have values and it's just
Well, but if this is-
but that's a very simplistic way of looking
at things, of course.
Yes.
But then there's a very interesting debate,
because look at today what is happening.
If you read any known regular book on robotics,
what is robotics and artificial intelligence
is doing out there in the economies, around
the world, in how many-you know in the next
decades or so, how robotics may displace millions
of jobs because menial jobs, or not so menial
jobs, may be done by, by machines.
So when I read this literature and I read
descriptions that try to compare us to machines
to digital computers, there I see a devaluation
of the human condition.
Because I start to think OK we are building
these robots to make burgers to clean floors,
to do you know this thing.
But we are not stopping to think what it would
mean to have 60 percent unemployment around
the world.
These are questions that we need to bring
as scientists, you know.
As I said, I love technology and I find that
it can be for the betterment of mankind, many
things that we're developing today, but some
of these issues have to be brought to society,
because society has to wait on them.
They have to think about what it means to
replace all these jobs, you know, in 20 years.
There's also the large-there's also the question
more generally of whether a purely physicalist
or materialistic account of human life is
compatible with some conception of the dignity
of the person.
It's a very, very important consideration.
You know, it's-and the argument can be made
that in fact, it isn't.
That it what?
That it isn't.
In other words-I mean, I'm one of those dinosaurs
who still uses the word "soul."
I know but, but if you call it the soul, the
self, whatever, you know, we're some sort
of psychosomatic unity, but we are compound
creatures in some way I'm speaking coarsely
here.
But if one has this conception, one does have
to worry about whether or not the reduction
of the individual to any single dimension
of the person, to any single dimension is
compatible with dignity.
Now I have to say the reduction-it may be
also, and I think it's true, that not only
is the reduction of the person to the body
maybe not compatible with dignity, but the
reduction of the person to the soul but also
leads to extremes of cruelty and so on.
And I think all that's true but, but I guess
my view also is that, and I think perhaps
one of the beauties of the human mind which
is why all the arguments about girdling incompleteness
I think is nonsense when it comes to the mind.
We can and we can even rejoice in holding
contradictory ideas inside our head.
And I'm, I'm fine with having contradictory
ideas inside of this, thing even though a
digital computer would crash if this sort
of thing happened.
I full well agree with much of what you're
saying, on the one hand, but on the other
hand, I say, "look maybe you're just devaluing
the scientific perspective."
You, know but I don't think
I don't, I don't necessarily find that that
describing myself in terms of molecules and
atoms and quantum processes taking place devalues
me.
In fact, it enriches me in much the same way
that Feynman was describing.
Forgive me, this is sort of the insecurity
that I find in certain scientists, not as
it's scientism science, which is what is threatening
to the scientific analysis of life when you
suggest that the scientific analysis of life
simply cannot account for all of it.
I don't know anyone in their right mind, who
believes that the scientific analysis of life,
in any of its versions, is false.
Right?
I mean nobody is arguing that we are not animals
or that we are not made of x % of water.
So what I don't understand is the need of
certain scientific temperaments to have it
all.
I don't, I honestly don't understand that.
No, I totally- let me just give one, one view
of it.
One view of it simply is, we're trying to
find the truth.
And the truth, and the truth, and the truth
could well be that all we are is, is the physical
and the physical through the wondrous laws
of physics is able to manifest in all these
wondrous ways where we can appreciate beauty
and we can love and we can be passionate and
it doesn't devalue it in order to understand
underneath, it's just the physical and it's
the urge to know what's true.
As opposed to a feeling of being threatened.
Let me just say for a moment.
I don't feel threatened by, as a scientist,
by what you said it all.
I actually feel that is a challenge.
It's a very good challenge to see if science
can penetrate in realms that it hasn't and
whether it can be accepted.
Whether people on a reasonable conversation,
like we're having you know, could come to
a conclusion that science has a saying in
some of these subjects or not.
I don't feel threatened about the possibility
that there are limits.
But I should just make a postscript saying
that I think we are not seeking the truth.
I don't believe in the truth.
I believe in the best approximation of the
truth that our brains can create because it
See, physicists are just more ambitious.
I know, I know.
But I think it's important that we, as you
said, when we go out and say what is the business
of science.
That we be humble and we have the humility
that is said ignorance brings, knowledge also.
Because the more we know, as you know very
well, the more we discover about this big
universe of ours, the more we know that we
know very little.
There is so much more to know and when we
talk about the human brain, boy believe me,
we know nothing.
We know a little tiny bit and we go out and
as you said sometimes say things that we shouldn't
say, that we know how this behavior is created,
how this option is made, and how we should
behave to be proper human beings.
And that's chauvinism.
There's a scientific chauvinism that I, as
a scientist, I cannot accept either.
However I do accept that we as scientists
should try to approach these big questions
and come up with the best shot we have.
But the thing I would say is that there are
different-the first thing that has to be recognized
is that there are different kinds of questions.
And that all the questions are not scientific
questions and all the questions are not philosophical
Questions.
There are different kinds of questions.
And I think that we have to recognize that
and sometimes when you recognize it- so for
example take, I don't know, a moment of courage,
take, you know, a soldier who throws himself
on a hand grenade and dies to save the lives
of his comrades.
Science of any kind, brain science, I assume,
could explain the operate -the how of that
act of selflessness.
How you know what was responding to what.
What was firing, what wasn't firing.
I don't know.
Neither do we.
Well good, I feel much more comfortable about
that.
Good, good, good.
Except that I have less excuse for my ignorance
than you do.
But the question of why those men did what
they did is a different kind of question.
And what I want to know why were they, each
of them, prepared to be crucified to protect
Spartacus who by the way was Kirk Douglas.
Yes, yes Kurt Douglas.
Spartucus
And when I asked the question why, when I
look for reasons, right?
I have to say science doesn't help me very
much.
But it may.
I think it may, well it may.
There are many reasons why groups of animals
may behave in a certain way for evolutionary
benefit, for benefit of the king, for benefit
of their offspring.
But it is the case.
I'm just saying that I don't I have the answer.
But I mean, correct me if I'm wrong, but isn't
that the case about- in evolutionary biology,
that the conclusion to which one comes to
is that the important factors are the variations
that what one winds up remarking upon most.
It's not that genes determine a similar course,
but in fact there's a wide variation.
Absolutely.
OK.
So then the question.
But social behavior is of a very fundamental
component of our species throughout the evolution
of various races.
Right, right, but what I'm saying is, that
in cases where what I'm saying is first that
the variations are not the answer they are
the question, for me.
In other words, I remember thirty years ago
some evolutionary scientists published a book,
trying to prove that men are basically biologically
hardwired for rape.
There was such a book, of course.
And then you know, and I read the book which
was very painful.
And, and as I read it I thought to myself
well, even if this is true, the fact is that
most men do not rape.
Right.
So how are we to explain the fact that a,
that a genetic instruction is being defied
is been now- clearly one has to conclude,
that we have the power, at some level to find
power any way you want, to act against what
some people would describe as a biological
direct -
But, but certain behaviors.
For instance the heroism or altruism that
you saw there can influence our brains can
synchronize brains to behave as a group.
And these mechanisms we are trained to unveil.
We are trying we studying their studies trying
to look at that what-
Right, but-
I'll give you an example-
Wait but I would describe that I mean, you're
absolutely right.
But I would describe that as the phenomenon
of moral influence and moral inspiration.
What I would say is that after the first man
got up-the first man who wasn't Spartacus
got up and said he was Spartacus, he gave
courage to the second man.
Now if you described it that way, you're just
you're in the realm of self interpreting beings
who have reasons for what they do, who have
feelings that move them now.
And I don't understand how that can be accurately
described except in those terms even if all
their genetic information was operating as
it was EIP et cetera.
But it could be that -the way I would rephrase
that, and I don't mean to put words in your
mouth is may not be accurate or phrasing,
it may be that the language that you're using,
the description that you're using, is so on
point for describing the human experience
that we see in that clip.
But, that doesn't negate the fact that underneath
it, there is a distinct language that uses
different words in different terminology that
nevertheless is also a completely and fully
accurate description of what happened.
Let me just take one out of the realm of emotions.
You know, if we see a baseball flying from
home plate to the outfield, right, we could
describe it using the language of quantum
physics.
We would have 10 to the 23 pieces of data
all describing
I'm never going to a ballgame.
That's right.
I mean would it be totally useless.
Which is my point.
You'd look at that and you'd say, "that's
impenetrable."
I don't know what that's referring to.
And then someone comes along, "Oh that's a
baseball flying to the outfield" and why say,
"Well, why didn't you say that?"
And the point is that language is so much
more economical, so much sharper in the description
of what's going on.
And it could well be that a version of that
story applies to the extent they are trying
to get them.
I don't think that the physicalist interpretation
of that hit could explain why the players
are playing the game or why the people are
there to see them play it.
I don't see how it could explain that.
And- but for those reasons that game would
not be taking place and that all or that physical
event would not be taking place over centerfield.
So in other words, I don't -obviously it'd
be insane to deny that the physicalist accounts
are not also true in the sense, but that they
describe what it is that they can describe.
Right.
But, but I would -I firmly believe that even
the truest of the physicalist explanations
does hit a limit if we wish to understand
the entirety of the experience that we're
taught.
And I think I can agree with that, because
I do also agree that it hits a limit in the
sense of the word that came after limit which
for you is understanding.
And I do agree at the level of understanding,
it is useless to give a certain kind of description.
However,
It may also be the case that there is nothing
else.
In the 19th century, in the 19th century some
of the ideas that I am rehearsing were developed
by German philosophers who basically developed
the distinction between explanation and understanding.
And you know these were German philosophers
who made a distinction between naturwissenschaften
and geisteswissenschaften, between natural
sciences and the human science.
Science is not the right word geisteswissenschaften
is sort of knowledge but- and that's exactly
what the idea was.
That there was an explanation and there is
understanding.
And the two are not the same and, and the
methods of explanation cannot do the work
of understanding and the methods of understanding
also cannot do the work of explanation.
I think that a great thing in physics would
call that the renormalization group.
I mean there is an actual technical version
of that scale by scale.
If we want understanding, we should use certain
language and certain degrees of freedom.
But in terms of explanation, it all rests
on the fundamental-
But you also have in physics, phenomena that
you cannot compute, the phenomena that you
cannot write an equation for and then and
solve that equation.
You know there are many functions many natural
phenomena that you simply cannot form
just because you saying it's too complicated.
Yeah.
Yeah and you cannot create an equation that
you can solve, you know, directly.
I just wanted to make a point at what you
were talking about.
To my point of view, is a moving border is
a border that we don't know where it is very
clearly and it changes over time is changing
with different knowledge gathering with different
experiences.
But I think the key, from my view, the key
point of this dialogue is that they are not
mutually exclusive.
I mean that border can exist and we can recognize
the existence of the border at this moment
because of our lack of knowledge.
And a thousand years from now, the border
may be so different that this conversation
will have a different quality to it because
of all that we knew at that point.
Who knows?
Can I just jump because we're running a little
bit of time, there's one subject .
I just want to say one thing quickly about
what did you quote the renormalization group?
Yeah sorry it sounds like a bunch of consultants,
I have to tell you, but I mean I don't know
what I'm what I want to say is this.
The
pluralism of languages that that seems to
accept the model of explanation and understanding.
I think that's wonderful.
But what matters is the spirit, also, in which
physicalists are scientists.
Except that in other words, sometimes I hear
that acceptance and there's a kind of scientific
condescension to the language of understanding.
That's just what poor humanistic creatures
tell themselves because they don't know string
theory or something like that.
Right.
And I think that we have to agree.
I think we have to agree that if we're going
to accept this double, this double-ness of
description, then each of the Realms is as
valuable as the other.
I would agree with that.
I just want to ask you one thing because it
came up a little bit and I know that when
we actually first discussed doing this program,
like last- at a Christmas party in the room
he began to talk about it.
You said you didn't want it to be sort of
a focus like debate on religion, which is
was just totally fine.
But can we turn to religion for the last few
minutes.
If that's OK.
We only need a few minutes.
It's just religion.
So here's my question.
Based on what I've read and some of your writings
and based on what you actually said earlier,
your view is that religion should not, you
know, sacred texts should not be literally
interpreted when we encounter those texts.
What we do is we interpret.
So is there a difference between that description
of a sacred text and how you'd say, talk about
Shakespeare?
I think that religion might be- religion is
a natural friend of science in the following
way.
The difference between the ancient medieval
conception of religion and the modern conception
of religion is that in the old conception,
which I hold religion was essentially first
and foremost a series of propositions about
the universe that are either true or false.
There is a god there isn't a god.
The world was created.
Matter is eternal.
There is providence there is chance.
But these were cosmological propositions and
religious thinkers relied upon science in
the way that some contemporary scientists
arrive at religious conclusions, sometimes
from their own scientific research, relied
upon science to arrive at the truth and their
idea was that whatever is scientifically the
case, in other words, whatever we know to
be true so that the medieval philosophers,
they held the Ptolemaic cosmology, right?
They were wrong.
But the centrality of the Ptolemaic cosmology,
for them, was simply saying that whatever
we believe to be scientifically true about
the world must also be found in religious
texts because if you are a believer who believes
that the texts tell the truth and if reason
and experimental research tells you that this
is the truth about the universe and the and
the and the verse says that the world was
created in seven days.
But geology tells us that it's so many.
Etc.
etc.
We're going to have to reinterpret the Scripture,
because the scripture cannot lie.
But what's special about our-
Now, I'll tell you there's a moment there's
a moment.
It's one of the most dramatic moments in all
of religious literature in Maimonides, where
Maimonides, who was a devout Aristotelian
and a devout Jew and he had the problem of
facing the question of whether or not the
world was created.
He had the problem that Aristotle believed
that the world was eternal.
Matter is eternal.
Where while in Genesis it said that in the
beginning God.
So my Monitise went to the painstaking trouble
of logically and rationally reviewing all
of Aristotle's arguments for the eternity
of matter and just and to his satisfaction,
which is saying something because he was a
very powerful mind, he came to conclude that
Aristotle had never definitively proved it.
And so what he wrote was and this had been-
Jews burned his book for this in the 13th
century.
He wrote that we continue to believe the account
in the scripture but if we could have proved
scientifically that matter was eternal, we
would have had to reinterpret the verses to
be consistent with scientific truth.
But why not throw the verses away?
So I don't mean that with disrespect, but
what was special about those word.
What's special about they're special to people.
No no no no no no.
That applause is way too easy.
Please.
I mean, no, what's special -it is those verses
are special to people who believe they are
special.
Yes.
If you believe that the Bible is the revealed
Word of God and you seek to be an intellectually
honest individual, you have a rough life ahead
of you.
There's a lot of work to be done.
There's a lot of debate and it will be easier
in some way as you say just to throw them
out.
But it would be disrespectful to people who
believe that what is same truth to throw them
out.
And so they are the honest ones are left with
the great task of reconciliation and that
to my mind, even though I'm not going to reveal
here my own beliefs, they're not exactly orthodox.
But to my mind that work of reconciliation
is a very noble endeavor based upon a very
high aspiration to intellectual integrity.
But why what is the problem of thinking about
religion as innate property of the human being
or trying to explain where it came from?
Where is everything coming from?
So I think that the first-
But then I think biology is that too
Sure.
But if I have a feeling that religion thinking
probably started the first moment the first
hominid jump from a tree, walk bipedal, and
look at the sky and saw that thing and said,
"Boy where that come from?"
I need to explain that this is quite something
that is part of our brain, is this obsession,
this craving for trying to understand you
know our origins are in the origins of the
universe, origins of our kin, origins of our
thinking.
So I am not a religions not religion religious
person.
But what I kind of think is that religion
can be seen as this craving for an explanation.
This is an attempt-
Well it's what Thales, remember?
Thales was looking at the sky, and of course
fell backwards down a well.
In the documentations, the paintings you see
the paintings that you see in the caves in
southern France, you know, law school you
know Altamira, these guys we're putting their
hands they're painting these animals in perspective
using the three dimensional distribution of
rocks to create the effect almost of a creation
you know image.
The attempt by means of reason to overcome
a mythological or animistic view of the world
was obviously is obviously one of the foundations
of our civilization, and nothing less.
My point is simply that not all religious
people are idiots.
And there's a certain kind of condescension.
Now many of them are.
But I have to tell you I have to tell you
I've met a lot of secular idiots in my lifetime
too.
I mean.
Look let me tell you why.
Let me give you one little example of that,
as we're running out of time.
I was invited to a closed door gathering a
number of years ago.
That was, I forget the exact name things like
science and the spiritual quest.
I though it was interesting so I went to it
and it was all Nobel laureates ,you know,
national- I thought that we were all going
to sit around the table and have nothing to
talk about.
Because I know we'd all sort of say well you
know you know there's not much to the relig-
and amazingly I was the only one who was coming
from a perspective that wasn't looking to
religion and spiritual as a as a vital part
of the truth.
I mean everybody is meant to give a presentation
I'm sitting there like with my jaw ajar as
like Nobel laureates singing psalms.
It was a very eye opening experience to me,
because these folks are not idiots.
And yet it's a vital part of their world.
It's
not a vital part of my world.
But Brian, look what happened there's a great
hilarious irony in the recent literature on
the evolution of consciousness, right?
Many of the people who mock you know there
is many religious people will sometimes, when
they can't their minds can't take them any
further and they don't want to lose their
faith, will talk about mysteries.
Right?
It's mysterious and people have mocked them
for it and that's sort of legitimate because
mysteries, the invocation of mysteries does
not explain anything.
It's like saying that something causes cancer
because it's carcinogenic.
Right that doesn't explain anything
Yeah just a different name.
But now, you have these diehard physicalists
who are running into real trouble explaining
the emergence of consciousness.
Real trouble.
I mean the real trouble.
There's no question about it.
And some of them now call the stem cells the
new Mysterians because what they say, these
atheists is that.
We can't explain how consciousness evolved
from matter.
But that doesn't refute our world view because
it's a mystery.
To which I think you know, brothers and sisters,
you have so forfeited your right to that word.
Right?
I mean you know their secular mystery is fine.
But so but so has religion with the word miracle.
No question.
Because science is making miracles when we
see the gravitational waves.
Yeah when you see the detection of the gravitational
waves come from the resounding waves of the
Big Bang and we can detect them a hundred
some years after a guy in a with nothing.
Paper and pencil
Not the Big Bang but rotating black holes.
Yes, yes absolutely.
Yep.
For me, that sounds like the closest of a
miracle
One that we can fully understand, which Einstein
himself predicted and which we can have supercomputers
yield a result for.
So it's a very specific use of the term.
But from the human brain point of view.
But there are two ways to use the word miracle.
One is you know in a cognitive rational way-
do you mean that it is actually a disruption
of natural law in some way?
No no no no, what I mean is
Or, wait, or when we say something is a miracle,
that's simply an expression of our feeling
of awe.
We don't have an- it's like telling a woman
that you'll, you love her forever.
You don't, you'll never you won't we won't
be here forever.
But you love her so much at this very moment
that "forever" is the only word you can use
to describe it
No, what I wanted to say or what I'm trying
to describe is when Einstein said the greatest
mystery of the universe is that can be understood.
Actually for me, there is almost a conflict
of interest there.
Because you know the beauty is that we can
think, we can create a theory, and we can
go there, create an instrument, collect this
data and verify that theory using the same
matter that generated that theory.
And that's what I call a miracle.
So I just want to jump off of that miracle
and that awe.
You know one of the things that often people
describe are transcendent experiences that
really somehow stand outside of some kind
of conventional scientists.
Well you know as I you know again I'm saying
I've got two views on all this.
It's been a fascinating conversation but I
do want us to end with some kind of experience
of awe.
And we have the great honor of having two
wonderful musicians who are going to take
us out tonight.
Joanna Kaczorowska and Pablo Lavandeira, if
you guys can come on out.
We're just going to end it with an absolutely
beautiful piece of music.
That will give us that experience.
So thank you very much, see you at other events.